now this Askren fight you're you're
fighting him in July that what is that
July 6th yes sir
when do you like how much of a camp to
yourself how much of like a fully
dedicated just all in camp if you look
at him
from a skill set Ben's not even worth
waking up before like 10:00 a.m. in the
morning but I don't like this dude man
before my alarm goes off I'm already
awake I want to break his fucking face
man I want to break his fucking ribcage
and I don't want to knock him out early
on I don't I just want to torture that
guy man if I get the chance to torch him
14 minutes and 50 seconds before I stop
him that's what I'm gonna do man you
know I just I don't like to dude and I
met him a long time ago he's a fucking
prick man I don't like him man
there's not too many people that I
genuinely dislike he's one of them
you know if I was a scene right now
probably wouldn't be too friendly of a
greeting you know now do you base this
on how he talks shit and just plays
around tries to hype things up or if you
had a like a real conversation with him
combination new things you know uh like
I'm the type of dude that um if we if we
train you go to American Top Team Joe
and let's say I get lucky and I tap you
out twice I'm not gonna ever tell nobody
cuz I that's not my glory moment that's
just fuckin training I don't give a fuck
about that I really forgot about that
but there's some people they violate
that man :
of gym you know I went to American Top
Team into like he's that type of of
pussy you know and I go he's talking
about gym stores Okemo to American Top
Team after I dumped him on his head we
kept wrestling he got scrambled me and
he said it yet you beat me rustling but
we were straight wrestling two-time
national champion you're proud of that
you're telling people that you know and
uh that just shows me he's character you
know he's not he's not who he pretends
to be and then he talks so much on mine
then I could have respected him a little
bit if he had held to his guns but I see
him in London and as soon as I see him I
start walking towards him goes hey man
I'm gonna spare you am I gonna say
nothing talk to your fight
Ben don't do me no fucking favors mom
you're not doing me no favors say
whatever the fuck you want when you want
it you know and address him and I went
up to talk to him and if she got
involved he put his head down and they
squirted him out of the hotel he never
came back to that hotel you know and he
actually wished me good luck at some
point - like right before like why are
you doing this man
you're not that person I'm on social
media that you portray to me you're not
you know so you're fake as fuck you're
selling something to the public that is
not there obviously and you're a coward
fuck it let's throw that in there too
and if people don't believe me tune in
July 6 I'll show you what how much of a
coward he is just to play devil's
advocate don't you think that what he's
doing is smart marketing to play devil I
know you don't like it I know you don't
like it but to play devil's advocate but
it's corny though I look back it's corny
like ain't nobody going oh he just wants
validation he wants to be accepted you
know I think half of what he's doing is
corny on purpose all that boom roasted
shit come on man half that stuff is
cornered on purpose no no that guy you
haven't seen him in yeah I got just
fucking corny so this DNA I like him you
can't I like talking to him he's smart
motherfucker I might be smart man but
he's a corny motherfucker round
just cause you for all the wrong reasons
I just can't wait I love the fact that
you're a purist like this though I
really do
I want to hurt that I know you do don't
wanna do it's gonna be a great fight
it's it's one of those interesting
fights because you've got good wrestling
takedown defense you've got very good
wrestling you got a very good takedowns
yourself but you clearly have a big
advantage in striking
yeah so it's one of those can he impose
his will
can I get a hold of you you get a hold
of these fucking numbers people talk
shit to me in the past but they'll say
to my face and mana game respect right
cool bro I'm a punk or whatever you call
you said it to my fucking face you know
but you say it online it's just the
whole way gets said about you say it
online then when you see me what's up
hey
picture because I fucking kidding me man
look is it weird I feel like I've been
brought out from like a Twilight Zone
from a different dimension sometimes
it's a lot of these rapper fighters that
you see acting like criminals on the
social media when they see me hey what's
up bro let me get a picture now fucking
fanboy doubt I go man I could've sworn
you were just mentioning my name singing
some shit bro that's fucking nuts to me
knows my mind right I'm such a simpleton
but it just blows my mind every now
you're a purist I don't know if it's a
pure simple I don't know where you want
to put me but it's not simple Sam I just
don't want to play that game you're not
interested in that game it's mine yeah
listen khabib zine interesting that
fucking game either yeah well he was on
top of Conor let's talk now damn let's
talk come on let's talk let's talk now
know that same shit purist I love that
humor I do I appreciate when that shit
talking has consequences
I like some shit talking though it's fun
she's hiding when you back it up yeah
back that shit up yeah
not you see me in a hallway lobby and
fucking run to security and get a
squirter down who's a guy you fought in
the past you had the most beef with
before you actually fought I mean
everybody had like yeah so not like this
fight like tell me you went back and
forth a little bit right no no no we
went back and forth like hey you want to
fight yeah let's do it I like it boom
boom boom but we never but it's pretty
respect yeah yeah
what about cowboy cowboy I mean yeah a
little bit of beef you know nothing
crazy like if I see him in the street
we're gonna start fucking fighting or
nothing you know is that what you mean
by like beef or just like yeah I'm
talking shit to each other oh yeah yeah
you're right mean cowboy we're talking a
lot of shit back and forth to it yeah
you know yeah yeah it's coming from
genuine places both sides you know so it
was good I mean it gave that fire you
know yeah yeah that's definitely one it
came from like a little bit of I did not
like this aspirin one Irish like the cap
we're going into that fight you know
obviously I think he's a fucking
stubborn he proves it again by having
the mo
wins most knockouts emissions do the
study
I don't think Askren is even yet to get
a win in the UFC you know I just think
about it like if I had fought Robbie
Lawler
which was a great champion and has done
amazing things in the sport since the
start of Robbie till now I think I still
fight him and I remember watching him in
the UFC back back in the day no see now
thirty seven and a half
what the fuck he came along seven and a
half deal fucking lean people still
count and look amazing and looks at yeah
it looked fucking amazing looked amazing
physically when he wasted Askren off the
air and dumped him on his head and then
started just driving his fucking
knuckles through his brain and it shows
you how tough Askren is the dudes
durables fuck man he handled that he's
built for survival even by his body type
you get so like physiologically he's
just built for a guy like me to put him
under the radar like all this guy's not
a threat look at him you know but it's
not gonna work I already know what to do
to this guy just fucking hurt him and
even the way he's fucking Billy's for
patheticness job but let's skip the
subject minutes ago somebody else met
this guy famous on your show that's too
late too late
well this man when they put his picture
up on them on the marquee he gets a big
pop that's crazy people love Askren I'm
I guess I don't know I haven't seen they
loved him before he fought in the UFC -
I never seen that cuz I I see I see I
saw in England in England they didn't
fucking hated his eyes they were booing
him out of the fucking stage he looks
like he belongs there
right he looks like oh you left us lad
he looks like an English guy doesn't he
I guess Millie doesn't that like what do
you think his nationality as Askren he
looks like he probably has some English
in him curly hair a lot of English dudes
are curly horse over there yeah you got
it bit the dude's got a while that's
wrestling style wrestling style it's
funky
yeah it's very unusual very effective
you know he's gonna have that wrestling
match with Jordan Burroughs it's gonna
be smash is that before or after yours
thing is before does that concern you
you might get injured do it fuck if he
does this cuz he faked the injury out
you know he knows what he's doing he's a
big boy you know I was like if you're
gonna fight Joe or Mayo
and uh one of your teammates might come
up to you and tell you like amen I think
you should fake the injury in the Drake
oh um I just faked an injury and cop out
of that fight you don't want no no
problems with that guy you know so I
might be what he's trying to do who
knows man